Today, we're going to
talk about using ares
for course reserves.
Just to level set--
course reserves,
if you're not familiar with
it, is course related material
that's made available, either
electronically or physically.
And generally, it's
the library that's
providing these services.
And at Yale, we use
a system called Ares.
It is the supported platform
for providing access
to these course reserves.
So just some brief information
about what the service is.
So it's a commercial,
vendor-supported software
package made by Atlas Systems.
At Yale, it launched
in the fall of 2013.
And it's been online since.
And the service is
managed by the library
and runs on university
ITS infrastructure.
So just talking about how
it's being used currently
across the university, Yale
College Arts and Sciences,
the graduate school,
and school management
are the key users
of this system.
Medical and law schools
haven't used it yet.
Just to give you a
sense of how it's
being used in the
activity in the system,
roughly 500 courses for this
spring that are using it,
about 10,000 reserve items.
And then, when it comes
to electronic resources,
there have been roughly
52,000 downloads this spring.
So it's a fairly
actively used system.
If you're unfamiliar
with Ares, just
to talk about the
various roles that users
play within the
system, so faculty
or their designated users
place things on a reserve.
And it's the library staff
that then takes those requests
and processes them and
makes them available.
And then, the students
view that reserve material.
I don't know if
you've encountered
other systems in the
past, if you've used Ares.
But in case you're
curious, benefits of Ares,
I think the biggest
thing, it's really
tightly integrated with Canvas.
So that's why we're here.
You gain access to it, using one
credential, one place to visit.
And you gain access
to that user interface
through Canvas, which is huge.
So instructors can place
reserve requests online.
You don't need to
come to the library
to do it anymore, to take a
book and put it on request.
That's all automated.
This is nice feature.
Instructors can arrange
and tag reserve items
to organize their courses.
So if you put 30 items on
reserve, you have a 15,
16 week semester, you
could tag it in such a way
that your students
know exactly when
to interact with the material.
And I'll show you an
example of them in a minute.
This is a big one, I think, for
the library and the university
in terms of risk.
There's a lot of
issues swirling around
about copyright and copyright
clearance for reserved items.
And the Ares systems
has a very nice workflow
that the library staff use
to validate that things
are, in fact, appropriate to use
in the class for your students.
And we will pay the
publishers whatever
fees are associated with
disseminating that information.
So you know that, if
you're using the system,
the material is OK to use.
And you're not going to
get a call from any lawyer.
[LAUGHTER]
Finally, it's a nice
place to go and check
accuracy of your reserve lists.
And much like Panopto,
you can get a quick sense
of what the statistical
usage is of the various items
on reserve.
Benefits for students--
a couple of nice things.
Again, tightly
integrated with Canvas.
They only have one place to
go to look at this stuff.
They have access to their
print reserve collections
and e-reserves
collection in one place.
So that's books that are put on
a shelf here in this library,
or it's links out to web sites,
or PDFs, or other materials,
all in one place.
For students, this seems like
it's a fairly popular service.
They can enable the system to
alert them when new items go
on reserve for a class.
So they get immediate
notification
that, hey, this professor
put this book on reserve.
They can also set it up in such
a way that it tells them, hey,
I'm going to set up a
reminder to remind me
that, in two weeks, I need to
look at this particular item.
And finally, this
solution is a document--
it's a place to
host the material.
So if you upload PDFs,
they reside in Ares.
So students can go and log
in, interact with the content,
or download it for later use.
So it's also a
publishing platform.
This is just one example
of a course in Canvas.
And you'll notice
here, circled in red,
is where course reserves
will pop up, I believe,
when you actually
populate that list.
And then, this is
the student view.
If you actually click through to
course reserves, you can see--
I don't know how big it is--
but on the bottom
part of the screen
are the actual items
that are on reserve.
In this case, it's
physical material
that, if they were to
actually click through
to any of those items, it
would probably say, oh,
go to the best library.
Go to CSSSI up the
hill, or wherever.
If it's web pages or web
resources, it's just links out.
If it's PDFs, you can
download the thing there.
Thank you.
So going to hand it
off to Mary Beth.
OK.
Hi.
I'm up at the hill at CSSSI.
But all the units who do
reserves and put things
on reserve for you work
together as a group.
We refer things out
to other libraries.
I just have a few
frequently asked questions
that I thought I would mention.
Do I have to provide the
material to the library?
No.
You can upload what you like.
We'll be looking at copyright.
So automatically, the default
is to check for copyright.
But you can tell
us, get it for us,
and we'll get the article
for you, or the book.
Sometimes, we don't
have the book.
We'll order the book.
We'll look at how many
students are in the class.
So if you know how many
students are in the class,
you can put that information
into the course record.
That will help us in figuring
out how many copies of a book
we need to have.
Do I need to tag
each reserve item?
It's a really good idea
to tag each reserve item.
Otherwise, it's hard for
people to find things.
We get frantic calls,
usually Sunday night,
my professor said there's an
article supposed to be here,
and it's not here.
Often, it's because they don't
know they can sort by tags,
or because it wasn't tagged.
And so they're having
trouble finding it.
And we usually calm them
down and help them find it.
What's a tag?
So if you say, this is
for the first class,
or the first week--
Oh, by time.
By time or date.
It's probably preferable
to do by class, in a way,
because if you reuse
a list, the next year,
the dates will be different.
So if you use the first
class, second class,
that kind of thing--
and for 0 to 9, if
you use 0-9, 0-1, 0-2,
0-3, so that it
interfile correctly.
It's fussy like that.
But that's part of the
few fussy things about it.
And you can tag them
with whatever you want.
If you want to use
topic, instead of time--
so this is the
topic we're talking
about for the next three weeks.
You can tag them
with time and topic.
Next question.
What is a pickup location?
We fixed it so it's easier.
There used to be a
default of Bass Library--
so if you didn't
catch that you needed
to choose a pickup location,
or your request for processing
went to Bass.
And since they're the largest
provider of reserves on campus,
that could have put you
back farther in the queue.
Pickup location is where you
would like print materials
to be for your students.
And that varies, depending
on what you're teaching.
CSSSI is the sciences, but
the engineering collection
is down here.
And so Bass provides reserves
processing for engineering.
Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] time.
We need to take questions now.
OK.
So thank you.
Any questions?
[LAUGHTER]
How much of a book will
the library [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
I was hoping someone
would do that.
So we have a guideline
that we will do 20%.
It's a guideline, so it's a
little soft around the edges.
But 20% of a book.
If the book is out
of copyright, and we
have the time and the
staffing, we can do much more.
But it's 20%.
OK.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]